ppl continue place au match des idées
maintenant confrontation de points de
vue ce soir entre roxane lundi eric
delannoy on va s'arrêter sur différents
points et notamment sur cette
intervention ce midi de marine le pen la
présidente du fn était interrogé par la
presse parlementaire sur plein de sujets
les régionales la souveraineté
économique mais aussi évidemment sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire l'occasion
pour elle de s'en prendre assez
violemment au gouvernement marine le pen
à l'offensive un sujet signé vendredi
[Musique]
marine le pen a les yeux rivés sur
l'élection présidentielle de 2022 mais
elle sait que pour l'emporter
elle devra rallier d'autres voies que
ses électeurs du premier tour en partie
à gauche où marine le pen vente par
exemple le positionnement d'arnaud
montebourg sur la défense des
entreprises françaises nous pouvons nous
retrouver avec un certain nombre de
personnalités sur des sujets qui
m'apparaissent très important et la
souveraineté l'indépendance nationale la
préservation de notre industrie
nationale est pour moi un élément très
important mais c'est vraisemblablement à
droite que marine le pen détient son
plus gros réservoir de voix
elle s'empare donc largement de thèmes
classiques comme la sécurité et site
largement le général de gaulle comme
référence en espérant attirer une partie
suffisante de cet électorat pour
l'emporter
la cohérence de mon projet j'en suis
convaincu
peut parfaitement convenir à des
électeurs à l'air en l'état je veux pas
faire de plan sur la comète mais en
l'état leurs candidats et dans
l'incapacité d'accéder au second tour
chez les républicains certains ont bien
conscience que le vote barrage au
rassemblement national ne sera pas
forcément appliqué en cas d'élimination
au premier tour
emmanuel macron a concentré depuis deux
trois ans
tellement de haine tellement de refus
tellement de rejet que le front
républicain à gauche ou à droite
d'ailleurs
m où sera de toute façon difficile pour
éviter ce choix aux électeurs de droite
les élus les républicains espèrent
surtout qu'une fois leur candidat
désigné une dynamique s'enclenchera pour
accéder au second tour où il s'estime
mieux placé qu'emmanuel macron pour
battre marine le pen ans tu es avec nous
pour le match des idées ce soir roxane
lundi bienvenue conseillère municipale
de beauvais membre de la direction
nationale de génération eric delannoy
bienvenue économiste et président du
cabinet tenzin conseil merci à tous les
deux alors le gouvernement a créé une
telle défiance qu'il que s'il disait
qu'il fait jour à midi un tiers des
français hésiterait à le croire
ce qui ruine les commerçants les
artisans ce n'est pas le covin mais la
gestion de l'épidémie par le
gouvernement voilà quelques-unes des
attaques lancées par marine le pen ce
midi devant la presse parlementaire
parlementaire est ce qu'on peut dire que
marine le pen a trouvé son angle
d'attaqué pour la présidentielle marine
le pen trouve toujours un angle d
attaque c'est celui de la colère qui
existe aujourd'hui dans notre pays ce
qui est dramatique c'est qu'après tout
ce que nous avons vécu lors de ce mandat
macro nist elle est aujourd'hui aux
portes du pouvoir et c'est ce qui est
malheureusement terrible dans le
discours qu'elle tient elle essaye de se
présidentialiser de montrer qu'elle est
prête à prendre le pouvoir et ça doit
nous interpeller puisque l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui peut l'emporter et
peut gagner il faut quand même rappeler
ce qu'est l'extrême droite quand elle
arrive au pouvoir ce qu'elle a toujours
été
c'est bien sûr un recul sans précédent
de nos droits de manière générale des
attaques faites à la démocratie et je
crois que nous la voyons qui apparaît en
tout cas renouvelée qui nous tient des
discours qu'elle veut moins radicaux
mais la réalité de l'extrême droite
concrètement ce sont des municipalités
comme un hénin beaumont où nous avons
jour après jour des attaques faites à la
démocratie avec une opposition
républicaine courageusement porté par
marine tondelier qui essaye malgré tout
de défendre nos droits et c'est la
réalité de l'extrême wade je pense qu'il
est vraiment important de continuer à la
caractérise et de montrer ce qu'elle est
concrètement et c'est là aussi que notre
responsabilité politique donc
responsables politiques nous devons être
en mesure pour 2022 de tout faire pour
que marine le pen ne puisse pas
l'emporter et tout faire pour qu'elle ne
puisse pas lent
orthez c'est d'abord combattre ces maux
le fait que de plus en plus les thèmes
de l'extrême droite sont les thèmes qui
occupent l'agenda politique autour
desquels s'articule le débat public ld
la politique et ça c'est un vrai
problème nous devons mener la bataille
sur ces questions et c'est une vraie
responsabilité que nous avons salut
honnêtement le travail qui est fait et
l'initiative de jean luc mélenchon qui
vise à faire en sorte que tout le monde
puisse se parler pour faire barrage
concrètement à cette offensive
liberticide qui existe qui est
orchestrée par l'extrême droite et par
les réactionnaires qui faisait mal parti
pour l'instant au delà de cette
intervention il ya les études les
sondages et ça ne vous a évidemment pas
échappé enfin j'imagine la dernière la
plus marquante c'est celle qui montre le
taux d'adhésion des 25-34 ans aux arènes
comment le rassemblement national est
devenue premier parti de la génération
des 25 34 ans titre un article du monde
qu'on voit ici dans l'oubli déjà par
l'oubli il faut corriger ça de mon point
de vue avec le fait que malheureusement
plus d'un tiers des moins de 30 ans ne
savent pas ce que c'est que la shoah par
exemple donc on va me dire quel rapport
entre de marine le pen la shoah on
l'évoquait l'instant les origines de
l'extrême droite c'est la collaboration
l'antisémitisme et on voit un par
rapport à certaines alliances qui peut y
avoir de marine le pen notamment au
niveau européen avec des partis
d'extrême droite extrêmement dur qui
sont pas loin des des néo nazis
on s'interroge sur effectivement là on
va dire le 21 octobre à vous dire mais
un parti elle doit être changée a le
droit d'évoluer je pense on n'échange
pas dans les aspects idéologiques puis
d'ailleurs l'histoire prouve que tous
les personnalités politiques qui ont dit
qu'elles échangent et n'ont jamais
changé en fait parce qu'en fait
psychologiquement c'est compliqué de
changer et puis il ya quand même un
substrat d'électorat notamment pour
l'extrême droite qui aux alentours de 3
à 5% qui sont eux la ligne dure de jean
marie le pen qui sont qui sont eux qui
font le party ce dont l'engagement du
parti au moins en termes durs il ya qu'à
voir le soutient encore deux ans encore
une fois du parti du rassemblement
national le soutien cif qui a eu par
rapport à génération identitaire cette
espèce de
groupuscules qui véhicule la haine dans
tous les sens et qui a quand même réussi
à avoir le soutien de duration l'hymne
national alors bien sûr quand il ya un
vrai clash quand il ya un vrai problème
battouta cours ou là là on se distancie
des personnes qui provoque ce clash et
on découvre que ces personnes-là
antisémites racistes ont tous un bon nom
participer à des groupuscules proches de
l'extrême droite donc la légitime un
romain gary disais vaut mieux perdre que
de se perdre en fait donc le front
républicain c'est un devoir ce n'est pas
une un calcul politique
c'est un devoir pour que la france ne
revive pas d'or ce dirt sombre car même
si on édulcore un petit peu l'extrême
droite dans ce qu'elle a de pire on peut
constater que tous les partis d'extrême
droite soit ont échoué soit ont
représenté effectivement la régression
des droits on peut le voir ball sonar où
on peut le voir en hongrie on peut le
voir tous les pays
le populisme représenté par les extrêmes
et je mets moi d'ailleurs jean-luc
mélenchon qui sont finalement pas très
loin le leur où je pouvais pas dire le
brun et le rouge se rejoignent un peu
ccc si mélenchon se sont se sont bien
reprises ici mais monsieur mélenchon le
problème c'est qu'un jour il dit ah le
jeu djouhri libé on sait pas trop ce
qu'il dit là bas mais leur fera le même
plan et font partie il a il a ce genre
de folie qui consiste à mettre sa
personne ce travail tracy s'est passé
pour moi les deux dangers sont aussi
aussi un portail
je suis en total désaccord avec ça et
d'ailleurs la question du front
républicain c'est une question
importante
la première des questions c'est comment
est ce qu'on explique aujourd'hui en
effet cette percée de l'extrême droite
chez les plus jeunes en mal génération
qui fait que toute la colère qui existe
dans notre société qui est légitime à
certains égards quand on voit
aujourd'hui la politique menée par le
gouvernement qui abîme la république
on a un gouvernement qui abîme la
république que ce soit par les décisions
qui peuvent être prises par la politique
du maintien de l'ordre qui aujourd'hui
est extrêmement problématique et nous
devons être en mesure d'apporter des
réponses à cette colère qui ne soit pas
simplement
et bien finalement l'extrême droite et
pour y parvenir nous avons besoin d'une
alternative crédible et cette
alternative crédible je ne crois pas je
n'ai jamais cru que ce puisse être en
tout cas l'extrême droite nous devons
démystifier cette idée oui il existe
aujourd'hui une opposition emmanuel
macron qui n'est pas marine le pen elle
doit même avant de gagner la présidente
marine le pen dit qu'elle va gagner la
présidentielle
j'ai qu'une chose à dire et bien que
cela puisse être entendue par tous les
partis de la gauche et de l'écologie
dans notre france nous avons nous avons
toujours eu une menace du front national
qui est extrêmement importante
nous avons vu ce que ça ne s'était
concrètement ce que ça nous a coûté lors
des dernières élections régionales où la
gauche et les écologistes ont disparu où
il n'y a pas eu d'opposition au conseil
régional où l'extrême droite a prospéré
nous avons besoin d'union et
l'initiative d'ailleurs de yannick jadot
de faire en sorte que tout le monde
puisse se parler et salutaire nous en
avons besoin
nous le devons aussi à ma génération
faire en sorte qu' un chemin d'espoir
qui puisse exister une alternative à
emmanuel macron qui ne peut pas être et
qui ne sera jamais l'extrêmement je vous
laisserai pendant quelques secondes on
adopte enfin je veux dire l'extrême en
tête aussi alimenté par une opposition
qui est totalement
morph qui ne proposent rien qui dans la
critique systématique sera donc qui
alimentent le ressentiment
quand on dit que la politique du
gouvernement abîme la république
moi je suis juste halluciné enfin julien
ne serait ce que dans la gestion de
cette crise on est le pays qui a soutenu
le plus les jeunes qui a soutenu le plus
les les entreprises qui ont soutenu le
plus les salariés home dans le monde
entier et malgré tout contre il ya une
tentative politique est une vraie
décision politique de repousser au
maximum le confinement pour essayer de
redonner un peu de liberté de souffle il
se trouve qu'avec le variant anglais
c'est compliqué bon enfin il a abîmé la
république ce n'est pas ça et donc
t'habiller la république qui pour
certains clients ont animé la république
c'est tous ces gens qui depuis trente
ans n'ont rien fait pour la france qui
fait que la police était en déshérence
que l'hôpital est en déshérence et c'est
eric serra d'ailleurs dont mails dont
don manuel qui a fait tout son pareil
pour tous est dans cette idée là les
gens étaient un certain laisser jean
d'âcre aujourd'hui donne la leçon sur
cinq années compliquées dans lequel tout
le ressentiment qui a été reçue rhji par
rapport au fait qu'on a laissé la france
en déshérence pendant 30 ans n'a pas été
géré et qui n'a pas géré la france c'est
la droite c'est la gauche qui n'offrent
aujourd'hui et en accédant rapidement
mais c'est intéressant mais je peux pas
vous laisser dire ça je peux pas vous
laisser dire ça parce que ce sont les
feulements est le fils de jean emmanuel
macron n'était-il pas le ministre de
l'économie tout simplement du président
françois hollande absolument celui
l'édition de la loi travail il ce n'est
t'il pas lauréat une maison et la loi
travail et des biens très bonne chose
travail d'immersion politique de casse
des droits sociaux des droits des
travailleurs mêlant contribué à faire
monter le front national en faveur des
banques les dunes alter ego sociaux
républicaine une autre un autre chemin
entre sur politique et interroge c'est
edouard philippe ça va sûrement vous
intéresser la sortie de son livre qu'on
lui donne aussi un espace médiatique
très important depuis quelques jours et
bien malin celui qui aurait compris ses
intentions pour 2022 son interview sur
france inter n'a pas donné plus d'un 10
ce matin on écoute un exploit mais
pendant l'intervention
lorsque le numéro 2 se pique de faire
autre chose que de gouverner ça marche
pas et lorsque le numéro un et c'est de
faire en plus de ce qu'il a à faire qui
redoutablement difficile parce que moi
je peux le lire
j'ai appris une chose à matignon que je
n'imaginais pas avant matignon c'est
combien présider et est redoutablement
difficile bien plus difficile que ce que
j'imaginais est bien plus difficile que
gouverner à mon sens
voilà c'est difficile on sait toujours
pas s'il va essayer d'être aussi mais de
toute façon à ce que les français
l'attendent alors c'est pas à vous que
j'ai posé la question tout de suite je
vais la poser à notre invité dans ce
match jean daniel lévy bienvenue vous
êtes directeur délégué harris
interactive france et ce qu'il l'attend
d'edouard philippe les français il
appelait cela le conduit ils sont très
bonnes opinions 2 à edouard philippe
mais on peut pas dire que spontanément
les français n 10
il nous faut edouard philippe comme
candidat à l'élection présidentielle il
ya pour cela je pense deux raisons la
première raison c'est que il ya la
perception attend voir raison qu'il dort
philippe est dans la droite ligne de ce
que fait emmanuel macron et qu' on n'est
pas dans un contexte où le corps le
coeur du corps électoral des manuels
macron se disent qu'il faut lui trouver
un substitut
ça c'est le premier point que le
deuxième aspect il ya certain regard qui
est positif c'est aujourd'hui une des
personnalités en qui les français
déclarent avoir le plus confiance mais
dans un même élan il a du mal à pouvoir
l'identifier autour d'enjeux politiques
et qu'il aurait pu être amenée à porter
la parole comme étant quelqu'un qui
avait été un bon premier ministre
de la part du président de la république
sans que pour autant il est à l'heure
actuelle une identité politique qui lui
seraient propres et singulière
contrairement par exemple à ce qu'ils
puissent passer par le passé avec par
exemple françois fillon voire manuel
valls il n'est pas aujourd'hui qualifiée
soit en termes de valeur soit en terme
d'identité sur eux mêmes en terme de
projet politique qui permettrait de dire
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils qualifient edouard
philippe ça serait ceci est ce qu il a
intérêt à être loyal ou rival je vous
pose la question est ce que vous avez
peut-être vu cette une de libération
loyal ou rival les français aiment la
loyauté non les français des français
aiment la loyauté les français aiment
aussi le propos politique ce qui est
intéressant vous avez tout à leur
montrer de l'interview à france inter et
c'est également ce qu'on a vu sur france
2 c'est que une fois qu on ait à la
radio ou le poste de télévision
on n'a pas une facilité à pouvoir savoir
ce que pensent vraiment aujourd'hui
edouard philippe quesne son regard à
l'égard de la société française quelles
sont les orientations qu'il souhaite
mettre en avant quelles sont les
thématiques et qui lui apparaissent
comme étant profondément prioritaire on
sait qu'il est historiquement ou issus
de la droite on sait où il va et fait
notamment de l'autorité
une partie
en fait de son action en tant que
premier ministre ça ne ressort pas
aujourd'hui dans ses prises de parole et
il ya plutôt un regard qui est un regard
autour de l'attitude qui peut avoir une
forme de nonchalance une forme de
sympathie une forme de bienveillance
d'une manière générale mais pas
forcément une capacité à pouvoir savoir
ce que pensent véritablement aujourd'hui
edouard philippe est donc dans ce
contexte là ce que se disent les
électeurs en tout cas ceux qui ont un
intérêt pour lui c'est on ne l'imaginent
pas prendre entre guillemets la place
d'emmanuel macro et un de ses seuls
ressort à l'heure actuelle nous ne
semble pas complètement dépendre de lui
mais semble essentiellement dépendre des
manuels macron de ce rapport à l'opinion
de son rapport à deux types de français
ceux qui se déclarent proches de la
réplique en marché et ceux qui se
déclarent proches de la droite
traditionnelle et parmi ces deux types
d'électorat il ya dans un match entre
guillemets entre emmanuel macron et
edouard philippe
une préférence en faveur du président
actuel restez avec nous jean-daniel on
va continuer d'en parler en plateau et
n'hésitez pas à intervenir si vous le
souhaitez il agace dans la macro ni ce
petit jeu auquel jouent edouard philippe
une espèce d'ambiguïté dans sa prise de
parole présidentielle 2022 le jeu ambigu
d'edouard philippe agace les maquereaux
nist a dit le monde
il agace ceux qui ne sont pas sûrs d'eux
en fait parce que finalement il n'y a
pas beaucoup de surprises par rapport à
ça tous les présidents ont vécu les
mêmes problèmes avec tout leur premier
ministre qui a aucune raison que ça
n'arrive pas cette fois ci
de quel droit on pourrait penser que
alors qu'il est sorti du gouvernement
tout à coup il devient on confond de
loyalisme et vassal isme exactement le
procès qu'on avait fait macron vis-à-vis
de choquer qu'il y aille eglin moi je
serais pas choqué entendons-nous bien je
sois pas choquer dans la logique de la
société du spectacle de ou en gros on
confond un projet politique avec des
personnes ça ça me choque
considérablement mais bon c'est un peu
je vois là c'est la poésie française est
ainsi fait
mais dans par ailleurs
qu'est ce qu'il a raconté en fait
edouard philippe sur le projet français
edouard philippe
il n'a aucune base électorale à part le
havre où il fait d'ailleurs de très
bonnes choses
il n'a aucune légitimité historique il
n'a aucune profondeur de pensée
effectivement il est plutôt venu dans la
macro ni pour en repartir et donc il n'a
pas non plus un corpus très important
c'est un grand conservateur et à titre
personnel je l' ai vécu six ans un serbe
de sujets notamment des sujets sociaux
donc voilà il va il va juste enfin
peut-être se remettent dans sa famille l
ère où il aurait légitimité à prendre le
lisent sur les nerfs peut-être mais
qu'est ce qu'il a à proposer moi je pose
cette question enfin après avoir partagé
pendant trois ans le pouvoir avec
emmanuel macron qu est-ce qu aujourd'hui
il va pouvoir trouver comme manière de
faire c'est à dire que quand on compare
l'émergence 20-20 d'edouard philippe
avec l'émergence d' emmanuel macron ça
n'a juste rien à voir rien à voir c'est
pas du tout les mêmes conditions
d'émergence
donc de mon point de vue ça serait juste
absurde mais les hommes politiques sont
ainsi fait que l'absurde il n'est pas
mais n'est pas un sujet pour que vous
inspire ce spectacle roxane langues
vous savez les débats internes à la
macro ni je pense ne sont pas la
priorité aujourd'hui des françaises et
des français mais de manière générale
edouard philippe était le premier
ministre emmanuel macron il est celui
qui a appliqué scrupuleusement sa
politique les orientations politiques
qui avait été prise par le président la
république il serait en effet
complètement décalé d'imaginer
qu'aujourd'hui mais andré nous expliquer
qu'il se présenterait comme une
alternative ce ne serait pas crédible et
je pense que ça ferait par ailleurs
beaucoup de mal à la politique que
d'imaginer en tout cas voilà que les
débats dgo puisse de cette manière en
tout cas revenir sur le devant de la
scène politique mais à quelque chose
d'intéressant et votre comparaison entre
l'émergence d' emmanuel macron et celle
du doigt philippe est assez intéressante
aussi à cet égard c'est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes arbres plus
d'un an voilà de l'élection
présidentielle et nous avons finalement
les mêmes débats et la même situation
que nous avions eu avec françois
hollande avant qu'il renonce à se
représenter
et ça doit nous interloqué scellier je
pense aux débats qui nous avions tout à
l'heure mais avoir un président la
république qui en pleine gestion de la
crise sanitaire dans un moment difficile
alors que tous on a les yeux rivés vers
lui pour savoir ce qu'il va se passer
avoir un président qui aujourd'hui n'est
pas forcément en mesure de repartir aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
pourrait peut-être nous le confirmer ou
non l'un sert mais il ne serait pas en
position où il a plutôt des bons points
emmanuel mais canon là pour la prochaine
présidentielle
dans le cas du premier tour il arrive à
fédérer son électorat qui est un
électorat qui a évolué au cours du
quinquennat
aujourd'hui c'est un électorat qui
proche plus à droite qu'à gauche et dans
le cadre des différentes intentions de
vote qu'on peut être amené à réaliser
il arrive à réduire sensiblement entre
24 et 27 % en fonction des
configurations au premier tour après ça
se complique nettement au 2e tour il
savait le lien va d'ailleurs avec le
débat précédent où il ya aujourd'hui une
double difficulté en entre guillemets un
front républicain qui ne se produit
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas l'intention
de voter contre marine le pen de manière
systématique autres cas de manière bien
monette en france avec un écart de cadre
à des intentions de vote qu'on a réalisé
qui est l'heure de 57 contre 43 pardon
contre 47 % de salaire six points
d'écart uniquement avoir des manuels
mapon et puis le deuxième point un
engouement qui est relativement faible
parce que on a des électeurs qui ne se
déplace pas et avec une abstention qui
se précise aujourd'hui comme étant
massim dans le cadre du deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle ce qui n'est
pas nouveau
va déjà à la dernière élection
présidentielle 25 % des français se sont
abstenus au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle ce qui était un record et
4 millions de français ont déposé un
bulletin blanc ou nul ce qui l'a aussi
été par record et on s'arrête là dessus
sur ce thème merci infiniment jean
daniel lévy à très bientôt sur ce
plateau on va parler de l'école
maintenant coup d'envoi chaotique
[Musique]
des bugs à répétition des millions
d'enfants et de parents bien perturbé
bien démuni une situation résumé dans un
tweet de la fcpe paris associations de
parents d'élèves
un an après ça recommence premier jour
de continuité pédagogique et le nt est
inaccessible combien d'élèves et de
familles ont le sentiment de revivre la
même un préparation encore et encore ça
c'était le début de journée fin de
journée peut-être un peu d'ailleurs pour
rattraper la boulette emmanuel macron
s'est invitée dans un cours en visio
avec des collégiens et il a eu cette
fois un discours plutôt optimiste et
côté on pense quand même que on aura par
cet effort collectif
là des quatre prochaines semaines bien
bien frais mais le virus
un peu partout et puis on aura continué
d'accélérer la vaccination est donc je
pense que jusqu'à la fin de l'année
scolaire ensuite il ne devrait pas y
avoir un nouveau de confinement voilà et
de et d'écoles fermées ou de cours à
distance voilà eric delannoy des
nouvelles relativement bonne peut-être
aussi pour rattraper un peu ce début de
journée à thé blanc oui alors toute
façon toutes les décisions qu'il prend
ou tout ce qui se passait bien
évidemment scruté à la loupe et c'est
normal maintenant on peut pas nier le
fait que c'est une catastrophe
un an après le début du premier
confinement dans lequel il y avait déjà
eu des bugs on se retrouve avec les
mêmes bugs
alors on peut dire que c'est des
attaques de l'étranger on peut toujours
dire s'ils sont visibles en cas dans
l'émission c à vous tous et non pas de
l'éducation et bien sûr mais c'est
bizarre parce que j'entends pas beaucoup
de grandes entreprises qui prétendent
avoir été attaqué toute la journée par
par l'étranger donc même si
effectivement l'état peut être plus
fragiles ou plus fragilisés moi ce que
je constate c'est que structurellement
que ce soit l'éducation nationale où les
autres administrations
on a un problème de bureau avec
réalisation qui fait que les projets ne
sont pas bien mené globalement alors il
ya des très belles expérimentation qui
sont faits avec l'état un jeu par sa
baie habitat point gouf qui est des
start-ups interne de la nation qui sont
créées capable de créer des plates
formes assez rapidement néanmoins
globalement les énormes admistration
qu'on a à gérer
ce sont des espèces de machines qui
bloque qui fonde le respect de la norme
qui fait que notamment pour des
plateformes éducation nationale on va
respecter des tas de normes donné par la
cnil sur le r gpd cette fameuse
réglementation sur la protection des
données sans se préoccuper d'efficacité
qui aura derrière les drones arias et
qui a freiné et qui aime bien sûr enfin
je veux dire aujourd'hui il y aurait une
solution simple face au bugue on
autorise les enseignants à prendre tous
les outils qu'utilisent toutes les
entreprises y pourtant les appels team
ce zoom va pas faire de pub mais il y en
a plein et bizarrement il n'y a pas de
problème pour ces milliers d'entreprises
ces millions de trouver ce qui tous les
jours
aujourd'hui depuis un an utilisent ces
outils là qui ce donc que ce problème de
respecter la norme avant d'être d'avoir
une efficacité opérationnelle ça sera un
des enjeux du prochain quinquennat pour
le coup on parle pas de réforme de
l'état sur les problèmes des coupes
budgétaires
il y en a marre de regarder la réforme
de l'état sous l'angle il faut faire
moins deux millions c'est la réforme de
l'état sous les formes de l'efficacité
par rapport au service rendu aux
citoyens plus la société du lien mais ça
c'est un autre sujet dont tout rapport à
l'air un autre moment je pense que le
problème majeur n'est pas un problème de
bureaucratie c'est avant tout un
problème politique puisque aujourd'hui
nous avons un président de la république
qui nous annonce la semaine dernière que
l'objectif principal de toutes les
décisions qui avaient été prises étaient
notamment la continuité pédagogique
la version quand même bien mis bien mise
à mal par ce qu'ont expliqué beaucoup de
personnel éducatif qui était obligé déjà
de fermer des classes de fermer des
établissements jour après jour compte
tenu de l'évolution du contexte
sanitaire et là nous voyons que malgré
les annonces de la semaine dernière qui
ont quand même tarder qui aurait pu
permettre de préparer cet accompagnement
est ce passage en hybridation complète
pour cette semaine bien au lieu de ça
nous avons aussi des bugs qui se sont
produits un problème d'impréparation et
là c'est pas qu'une question de
bureaucratie c'est aussi une question de
moyens
deux objectifs politiques composent et
de moyens financiers qu'on met en face
pour faire en sorte que tous ont eu
beaucoup de profs dire que rien n'a
changé dans l'éducation nationale et
dans les blogs
ils n'ont pas donné parce que la chaîne
de commencement lâcher de laquelle la
chaîne de commande en parts dans la
chaîne d'exécution
elle est compliquée regarder si on
prenait cette espèce de mammouth ce ce
terme majeur qui est utile il ya
quelques années
l'éducation nationale c'est linafoot et
l'inefficacité mêmes fins et des normes
ce n'est pas d'hier c'est mais bien sûr
tout n'est il ya aujourd'hui mais en
chiffres on peut le donner en chiffres
par rapport aux allemands qui sont
toujours une référence même si on
pourrait les comparer le l'appareil
administratif par rapport à l'appareil
d'enseignement de ligue nationale
française c'est un désastre
le coût des élèves par par ton par
rapport à l'efficacité de cet
enseignement c'est un désastre
et puis on peut prendre tous les to les
toutes les commandes et à geler les le
pisa on peut faire aujourd'hui la seule
chose qui fonctionne bien qui a été une
décision prise dès la nomination
d'emmanuel dacron si les dédoublements
des classes sont ces pays ans est là
mais ça pour le coup c'est bizarre tout
le monde avait dit à l'époque que
j'étais pas vos cils l'opposition de
syndicats compris aujourd'hui on
constate que c'est franchement efficace
et que c'est une mesure très systémique
pour lutter contre les inégalités des
changes mais vous pouvez pas dire ça
vous pouvez pas les quatre chanteurs
d'asnières enfin de cette manière
l'éducation nationale c'est beaucoup
plus mais c'est vrai toutes les
distractions
je vais même vous dire une chose
l'éducation nationale le travail qu'on
fait les personnels éducatifs qu'ont
fait les directeurs d'établissement
c'est le travail que n'ont pas fait des
politiques très souvent mais c'est pas
là on travaille là nous avons des
professeurs nous savons bien que c'est
le travail l'école c'est pas parce que
rire en regardant la télévision en
regardant jean michel blanquer air à la
télévision qu'elle était les nouvelles
consignes à défaut d'avoir des
directives et non pas une directive ça
c'est vrai les directeurs d'école vous
le disons mais bien emmanuel ce n'est
pas jean michel blanquer requis le soir
dans son bureau appuie sur un bouton qui
fait que tout le monde les informations
dans ces banques ont bien sûr un plateau
de télévision et qui a dû ce qu'elle
veut ce n'est pas du tout un cercle à
des jeunes
une entreprise fin quand je suis chef
d'entreprise dont je vois la difficulté
qu'il y as entre quand un patron donne
une directive comment ça s'applique mais
imaginez dans un dans une administration
et dans un pays mais c'est un problème
politique c'est un polar d'exécution
garder le global à côté de ça ce que je
vois aussi c'est qu'on matière
d'exécution alors que nous avions des
défaillances de l'état qui en matière
d'éducation et été soulevée par tout le
monde 1 sur la gestion de la continuité
pédagogique
nous avons des personnels qui ont assuré
la débrouille et sony mais l'exécution
ces palabres où jack des zones urbaines
acteurs d'établissements ont été avec
leur petit caddie acheter l'humilie
droit biblique mais bon ça traduit bien
ce que je dis c'est qu'ils intervenaient
déjà l'idée d'avoir un bon problème
d'inefficacité ça pouvait bien sûr pour
ça des gens sur le terrain je suis amusé
aux manquements mais non que j'aie
jamais thème qui veulent en turquie va
avant que vous allez adorer joris
mention aussi presse a permis d'en
parler un petit peu c'est le dernier
thème de ce match c'est l'avenir d'air
france l'état annoncé la
recapitalisation de l'entreprise après
l'aval de bruxelles ça peut poser
question d'ailleurs nouveau plan de
soutien de 4 milliards d'euros après
celui de 7 milliards en 2020 une bonne
nouvelle nous dit le gouvernement
attention aux contreparties sur l'emploi
et sur l'écologie nous dit les positions
beaucoup de questions sur le sujet tout
à l'heure dans l'hémicycle lors des
questions au gouvernement écouter ce
moment où bruno le maire en profite pour
régler quelques comptes avec les
écologistes
si je me permettais je vous dirais que
vous ne manquez pas d'air
[Musique]
parce que attaqué autant que vous le
faites de transport aérien tout en
demandant d'un autre côté de le soutenir
sa demande pas d'air quant aux reproches
que vous nous faites d'avoir attaqué
collectivement la maire de poitiers vous
permettrait de confirmer que je ne
souhaite pas et que personne ici ne
souhaite que les responsables politiques
s'occupent des rêves de nos enfants que
ce soit bien dit une fois pour toutes
[Applaudissements]
mais je veux vous rassurer et je veux
vous rassurer votre collègue de poitiers
je veux rassurer tous les verts nous
continuerons à soutenir massivement et
durablement le transport aérien les pme
qui travaillent dans l'aérien le secteur
aéronautique airbus
toute l'industrie française qui fait
notre excellent sans le transport aérien
un règlement de compte donc avec les
verts et notamment la maire écologiste
de poitiers qui je le précise pour les
téléspectateurs qui n'auraient pas suivi
avait déclaré c'est triste mais là et
rien ne doit plus faire partie des rêves
d'enfants
aujourd'hui mais de quoi parle t-on vers
quoi parle t-on bad d'un plan
d'investissement de l'état à hauteur de
4 milliards d'euros 4 milliards qu'on
est en train de comparer à une
subvention pour un club à hauteur de
4000 euros
voilà c'est ça la réponse du
gouvernement et c'est terrible les
propos de monsieur bruno le maire et je
trouve même que c'est un aveu de
faiblesse
absolument incroyable on lui fait donc
si peur que ça pour aller expliquer que
l'opposition aujourd'hui prend des
décisions insoutenable parce qu'une
subvention de 4000 euros n'a pas été
donnée alors que dans le même temps on a
investi quatre milliards d'euros
quels ont été les demandes et qu'est ce
que nous formulons c'est tout simplement
qu'on ait fait nous puissions avoir des
contreparties économiques écologiques et
sociales c'est ni plus ni moins que ce
que demande l'opposition assez
constructif que de faire de telles
remarques
il souhaite toujours amis il assure que
ce sera le cas une bouffée d'air france
la compagnie la plus verte du monde
moi je veux bien mais dans ce cas est
dit il faut il faut poser les choses et
regarder les faits il y avait une
demande
ce qui était de privatiser aéroports de
paris la gauche et les écologistes se
sont opposé à cette privatisation en
disant que c'était toujours pareil on
privatise et quand il y avait du profit
qu'on mutualisaient quand il y avait des
dettes et de l'investissement d'ailleurs
la ville la situation nous a donné
raison en raison de la crise sanitaire
il est frustré mais il va falloir que je
termine cramé mais aujourd'hui nous
demandons tout simplement est ce que
nous puissions cesser cette manière de
faire est que nous puissions avoir des
garanties qu'ils soient plus fortes le
compte n'y est pas aujourd'hui a répondu
moi je suis toujours je suis toujours
très impressionné par la créativité de
l'opposition pour vous critiquer tout le
temps en fait oui ce qu'on ne comprend
pas dans cette histoire là c'est la
dynamique d'une entreprise en fait une
fois de plus d'abord le plan écologique
d'air france a démarré depuis très
longtemps et ça bizarrement vous savez
pas mais sur la manière de rouler les
véhicules sur le tarmac pour économiser
des milliers de ces de co2 le les
commandes les commandes d'avions et la
planification de l'eau d'avion pour que
pour faire le moins de kérosène
donc les garanties elles sont déjà là
l'idée politique stupide qui
consisterait à dire on va donner 4
millions air france pour tout de suite
avoir des garanties de résultats sur ce
qui se passera dans dix ans si ridicule
ça montre que la dynamique d'entreprise
rien n'est pas connu aujourd'hui quand
on donne 4 milliards d'euros à air
france on fait en sorte qu'air france
survivre parce la crise réussissent à se
recapitaliser et puissant en fait mettre
en place son plan stratégique dans son
plan stratégique il est noté noir sur
blanc et des actions sont déjà
enclenchées les garanties que vous
demandez donc vagin ses défauts problème
at il donc là ça n'est qu'un jeu réalise
l'aide quand un copain mais n'ont pas dû
tourner bien sûr que si mais pas du tout
on comme utilise pas du tout simplement
des garanties ont fait en sorte de faire
en sorte qu air france n'est pas une
dette à rembourser mais affiche des
résultats pour que ces résultats
rembourse la dette sont très différentes
à française et ses gosses ils
contribuent absolument fabuleux
conte intérêt à 30 ans soit renflouée
mais que la suisse était un faux
problème
quant à comparer poitiers et cette chose
là mais c'est là encore c'est vraiment
bizarre quoi on parle pas d'argent on
parle pas des 4000 euros quand les 4
milliards mais parle d'une dune du d'une
proposition maire qui dit n'importe quoi
en fait sur les enfants c'est ça le
sujet c'est pas tellement le sujet de
ceux de soutenir ou pas le secteur
aérien
c'était ça le sujet merci désolé je
savais que vous seriez fou et je vous
promets voudrait avait déboursé sujet
c'est pour ça on avait une liste des
concerts budget et merci à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à ce match fin de
cette émission sur ton de demain à 18
heures et à 22 heures 30
bonjour chez vous dès 7h30 demain matin
oriane mancini recevra julien de
normandie ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation excellente soirée
[Musique]